imagine having to surf to get home then
imagine doing it after swimming 300
miles in the roughest ocean on the
planet not to mention the seals waiting
for their charts to rip your little head
off this is just a single day in the
extraordinary life of the macaroni
penguin how is it possible that life can
come back from the dead the island of
South Georgia was the scene of one of
the worst wildlife massacres in history
species driven to near extinction the
whaling stations were abandoned this is
an all inspiring story of how if given
the chance Nature can bounce back on a
scale you're not going to believe
my name's Bertie Gregory and I'm a
National Geographic wildlife filmmaker
this is Resurrection Island
[Music]
this place is the holy grail of wildlife
filmmaking as at this time of year it's
home to one of the highest
concentrations of wildlife on the planet
right now over two million macaroni
penguins of returning to raise their
young ones after swimming miles in
search of prey these little guys need to
reach their chicks at the top of the
cliff giant waves razor sharp rocks and
hungry seals may kiss no piece of cake
the Maxime skittish something is
spooking them but I don't think it's me
with a predator on the hunt they must
aim and shoot to get on that
the anglers and totally bonkers makes it
to cheese the biggest way
begin the beguine
run a monitor onto the rocks flip right
over they come through all underwater
visible he disappears try again they get
sloshed shoot and hope you land at the
right rock
[Music]
[Applause]
it might be tiny but they're tough to
keep up with though it shows this to the
insurance company
there's no time to chill the chicks are
waiting for food and there's still a
long way to go the Macs have got to be
much more than just pro surfers they
need to be mountain climbers to
[Music]
completing their first mission down on
the giant wavy Rock they've now got to
make their way up to the colony up to
where the nest sir but they've got a bit
of a secret route down here it's like
being in some kind of some kind of
fairytale finally home they still have
to find their family and of course don't
even think to ask your neighbor
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's just so horrible for their
neighbors
every time a stray runs through that
right there is what this is all about
just underneath that adult my panda is a
little gray chick it is so funny anytime
any of the other adults comes anywhere
near the next adult it's like no no no
not here I've just pecks it to pieces
yes mums made it back it's crazy to
think that this pair returns to exactly
the same nest year after year
unfortunately these penguins don't have
much family time the parents must divvy
up daycare and now it's dad's turn to go
out to see the trek out to see is packed
full of its own dangers so the max need
to tread carefully
fur seals feed mainly on fish squid and
krill but on very rare occasions they
hunt on land
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's not often you see
something that raw and unfortunately
whilst that little macaroni that was
being thrashed around did manage to get
away from the first seal it hasn't
survived it's being eaten by a giant
petrel and that's the circle of life the
giant petrels got its own chicks to feed
and I think the the takeaway from that
encounter was not the one that hasn't
survived it's the one macaroni that then
stood up to that same predator and in
the face of danger just said come at me
wings out you know the bravery the sass
that these penguins have got is just
remarkable and it will produce checks
that have an equal amounts of sass and
that is what natural selection is all
about it's survival of the fittest only
the best will go on to produce offspring
climate change is affecting ocean
currents and forcing max to swim further
and further for food tied to their
nesting Islands this ultimately means
less food for the chicks
so despite their toughness max is
declining in number even for this
massive colony Big Mac the future
remains uncertain for this special
little species
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]